well the countdown is on circa opened in
downtown las vegas in the middle of a
pandemic
and now all eyes are on resorts world on
the strip
anchor kirsten joyce joins us live with
a peek and so much excitement
on this property hey kirsten
hi christian yeah resorts world opens up
in one month to the public on june 24th
as you can imagine it's exciting it's
all so hectic as things last minute
things need to get done
take a look behind me as we zoom in
there the property will be the first new
resort to be completed on the strip
since the cosmopolitan which opened in
2010
but before we get to everything that
resorts world is going to offer
let's take a look back in time
on july 2nd 1958 the stardust opened in
las vegas as the world's largest hotel
it had more than 1 000 rooms a 16 000
square foot casino which was immense for
its time
the stardust iconic sign was the strip's
largest 216 feet long
rising 27 feet above the casino's first
floor it displayed the entire solar
system
the stardust was operated by men
associated with chicago and cleveland
crime syndicates
who skim millions from the resort a
scheme that inspired the movie casino
what's the matter with you did you see
your view in 1983 a federal grand jury
indicted 15 people and controversy
surrounding mob ties with the property
ended
when sam boyd purchased the stardust in
1985
the stardust modern casino and 32-story
tower were built in 1991.
[Music]
later that decade at the age of 57 wayne
newton signed the biggest entertainment
deal in las vegas history
[Music]
performing exclusively at the stardust
40 weeks a year
at the end of 2006 the stardust closed
its doors for good
it was imploded on march 13 2007.
boyd gaming announced that the echelon
place was to become the centerpiece of
the new north strip
gracing 87 acres where the stardust and
westward hoe used to sit
it was to include 3 300 hotel rooms and
a 500 million dollar shopping promenade
but it fell victim to the great
recession and construction was halted in
2008.
the history of the city and what and
what made it what it is today
boyd sold the stardust site in 2013 to
malaysian company genting group
and resorts world began developing the
hotel is massive featuring 3 500 rooms
more than 40 food and beverage spots 250
000 square feet of meeting space
117 000 square feet of casino space
and you can't miss the largest led sign
visible from across the valley
and the outside is amazing wait you see
all the led inside the property
there's a five-story globe in there that
that's a mirrored led only thing like it
in the world
so there's a lot of fun things that we
must see attractions
inside the property resorts world
president scott sabella says this is
just what las vegas needs coming out of
the pandemic
it's exciting to see that las vegas is
starting to rebound
this city is resilient we've proven that
in the past that it will bounce back
faster
and we're excited that we're happy we're
going to help the city rebound faster
and thanks to photojournalist chris
benka for pulling all that cool historic
video right
well coming up throughout the hour we're
going to talk about the hiring spree
underway
and also how the resort is appealing to
visitors and locals alike